Oops.
Forgot to turn on the music.
Welcome.
You like my hat?
Thank you.
I am a being to be feared.
I am...
The creature.
Today we're fishing.
Whether we're web fishing...
If hopefully all goes well...
I don't know.
Someone might be editing this at this very moment into a subtle foreshadowing type clip at this very moment.
If all goes well...
We will be web fishing.
And if not, then...
There's other fish in the sea.
In a different pond.
In a different location.
Yeah, my PC might explode.
That would be really exciting.
You look like you just finished your shift at the Krusty Krab.
Kind of.
Morning, Kevin.
Good morning.
I'm so sleepy.
Such a lazy Sunday.
And I have to go out later.
I have to go...
I have to leave my maid cafe, which is why...
Today is kind of early.
But I just feel lazy.
I don't want to do anything.
I'm tired.
I'm drinking my tea.
And I'm looking at web fishing.
Is this the Krusty Maid?
Don't call me that.
Don't say that.
Oh my gosh.
Don't call the Krusty Maid.
You changed your clocks.
Yeah, wait.
It automatically...
It automatically changed.
On my phone and my computer.
No, this is Patrick.
Joshua!
Can I travel my community for my first happy birthday song?
Of course.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Joshua.
Happy birthday!
The recordings are the vibe gifted.
Wow, I just got dumped last night.
I
don't know what to say.
Uh...
They sucked?
Stick with Vtubers?
I'm sorry.
Yeah, I did say that there's plenty of fish in the sea.
I hear there's a cool new Vtuber, Spaghetti-chan.
Who's that?
What a silly name for a Vtuber.
What a silly name.
What if I create code only?
Can I get one minty patty, please?
Ducky, I saw your off-stream.
Don't know, I saw it.
I saw it.
I see y'all.
Sorry.
At this point, I'm not surprised at what people draw me as.
Sometimes.
I think the only thing I wouldn't want is like a...
I don't know.
I shouldn't say it because then people might draw it.
You know?
My voice is still a little icky today.
It's not great.
Currently designing a fishing minigame.
It's a lot trickier than I thought, but I think we'll have something cool soon.
Every RPG needs one.
It's true.
Every RPG needs a...
needs a fishing game.
Pasha Miiin!
Hello!
Hello, hello.
Long time no see.
Every RPG needs a mint spooky ghost.
Yeah.
Lampy!
Thanks for the gift.
Thank you, thank you.
So, let's ignore these losers.
Start the game.
Nice key!
You guys, look at me.
It looks just like me, doesn't it?
Because I'm like...
dead.
And I fished some pants.
It looks just like me.
Grease stains?
No, that's my...
that's my pattern.
That's my pattern, that's my pattern.
Pattern.
It looks just like me.
Press G?
What's G?
The song of my people.
You can also hold...
hold CTRL when you press G.
What the heck?
Mean mugging me.
What is that?
What?
This is not a meow, this is... he's hissing at me.
Alt G?
This is how Pai sounds.
Every time I see her, she like chirps a little.
It's so cute.
Press K?
Oh wait, I should... towards the cat.
Hey.
Towards the cat, towards the cat.
See, this cat really is me.
What else can I press?
Typing slash wag.
Oh, enter.
Oh, I have a short tail because...
that's just like...
Butaro has a small short tail, so...
I based that off of him.
So cute!
How do I... OK, zoom out.
So I only did the tutorial last night.
So I don't really know anything about the game.
You can also make expressions by typing...
Oh.
Wait, does it say what I type?
It does!
It says what I type!
Oh no.
What else can I type?
You can change the voice pitch too.
Wait, how do I do that?
Wait, how do I change... Wait, is it here?
No, it's the quest board.
In the backpack.
Oh, customize.
Miscellaneous.
Oh, voice pitch!
Hi.
Like Super Moe voice.
I have 68 books.
Books.
It sounds like...
It should be illegal to be this cute.
I know my cat is like...
Does pitch change the meow?
No.
C opens the...
No!
What is this?
Oh my gosh, cute!
Sit.
This game is so cute.
Oh, I'm still sitting.
Oh wait, how do I stand up?
Oh gosh.
Oh no, what was it?
Wait, what was to bring up the menu?
Oh, not K.
Oh, C.
What's this one?
Ahaha.
Catmit was just spitting some facts then.
It doesn't sound so much like what I was typing before anymore.
Sometimes I hear it.
Oh, my voice is really bad today.
I'm sorry guys.
I forgot to take my medicine.
That helps my throat.
Wow, I just want to look around real quick.
Oh no, I'm nervous though, because I didn't realize I thought only the chat box worked.
I didn't think that also...
Birds.
I didn't think that also it would show up above their heads, so hopefully nothing bad happens.
Hopefully, we're okay.
Wow, is this a magic mushroom?
Yeah, I'll probably make the code a members thing.
So, yeah.
We'll see how it goes.
Right now, I'm just exploring a little bit.
Oh my gosh, can I fish from here?
Sit.
Reminds me of Outer Wilds.
Right!
Wait, it's raining.
No.
I can't fish though.
Oh my gosh, my face.
I don't think I... Oh wait, what?
Here I go.
Fish!
No, I can't fish from here.
So sad.
Again.
It is kind of Outer Wilds-esque though, isn't it?
Oh, it's raining.
Does that bring out rarer fish?
Middle mouse click to rotate without...
I still have to do this though.
Wait, how do I get down?
I'm trapped up here?
Uh oh.
What's happening to me?
What am I doing?
What's going on?
What just happened?
Okay, here I go.
We're fine.
Everything's okay.
There's like... The music is kind of inconsistent.
Oh shoot.
Oh my gosh.
I'm gonna die out here.
Can I drown?
Oh, kind of.
I can kind of drown.
What was I gonna say though?
Oh, what's down there?
A pathway.
Okay, we have to be good.
We have to be good at the game.
Oh.
Oh shoot.
No.
Oh, we're good.
Secret.
What is this?
Parkour.
Thanks for the gifteds.
Oh no!
Oh, what the hell just...
Oh my goodness.
Oh my God.
Why do I leap sometimes?
And why do I sometimes...
Just jump.
What the hell?
GS5 dive.
It's true.
Hello.
Jump in the air is a leap.
Oh, it's a double jump.
I see, I see.
Okay.
Oh my gosh.
The tutorial didn't teach me the double jump.
I don't think.
Is that a fish right there?
Oh my gosh.
Hold!
Oh gosh, I'm not fast enough.
Smash, smash, smash, smash.
I got a whole lobster.
What a beaut.
Holy moly, I got a lobster.
I just gotta make the next one.
Nice!
I got a new creature.
It's a spectral...a spectral.
That's me.
A spectral...
Spine, you feel another...an otherworldly...
I'm already carrying this bone.
Wait, what do you mean by that?
What's an otherworldly presence?
What?
I'm collecting a bone?
Bone!
Spooky.
Spectral spine.
Did someone die there?
Exciting.
Oh my gosh.
Thank you, luck.
Thank you.
What a thrill.
Wait, is there like spooky stuff in this game?
Can I find it all?
Can I find all the spookiness?
I'm haunted now.
No.
I'm already a ghost.
Dang.
We almost made it.
Wow, this game is crazy.
I didn't realize it would be so huge.
Oh.
And spooky too.
I'm gonna put on my own music.
Let's do this.
Settings.
Music volume.
I'll put on my own music.
Even though I like the music in this, it's kind of Minecraft where it's...
Where it's inconsistent, you know?
Give me a second, I don't want to blow out your ears.
There we go.
So how was your weekend?
Almost died again.
Wow, there's so much in here.
There's so much in this game.
Can I walk through here?
No.
Chill?
I caught a super rare fish this weekend.
Let's go.
Didn't someone say, Fungi, that you have like a thousand hours in this game?
You have like the most hours ever in this game?
I only have 50.
I'm gonna explore just a little bit more around.
And then I'll let people in.
And then I'm just gonna fish.
And then we can chit-chat.
Today's stream isn't gonna be super duper long.
Let me know if also the BGM's a little loud.
But, um...
But, uh...
Whoa!
Closer!
Thank you for the 50 gifted!
Thank you!
A little loud?
Um, not super long since I'm gonna be touching grass today.
And, uh, you know...
Simple thanks for the 5 gifted!
I got a blue fish.
One fish, two fish, red fish.
Guys, I'm gonna become rank 2 scout soon.
Soon.
Where are the other secrets?
The mushrooms must be the key.
The key to the dead bodies.
Making a multiplayer lobby with the password makes a server, but you need to reach the helicopter from multiplayer menu.
I see something!
Oh!
Oopsie.
Oh, good.
Right here.
I see secret.
I need to reach the helicopter.
Where?
We made it!
New creature.
You caught a spectral rib!
Scary.
It's more ghost stuff!
I've got the bones.
Oh, wait.
Oh.
Oh my god.
Oh, Devon!
Thank you for the 20 gifted!
Thank you!
And Stuff Sharky!
Thank you for the 10 gifted!
Thank you!
What is this house?
Who is this?
Oh.
Gold watch.
Metal detector.
What?
Scratch off?
Props.
There's so much in this game.
I can get a sword.
Requires three blade fragments.
Oh, wow.
Oh.
OMG, thank yous.
Wait.
I didn't... I thought it would...
Ask me if I wanted to...
How do I do it?
Oh!
Went up to $10,000?
Fishing in there.
Wait, how do I do this?
When any winning number matches a number, win the cash.
Do I just scratch the whole thing?
Scratch the whole thing.
What do you mean I didn't win anything?
I didn't even finish scratching!
No.
One more try.
I have enough money.
We're gonna win something for sure this time.
Okay.
What was that?
It just flew by.
$200.
Try.
It's telling me to try again.
I won $10!
Yeah!
Now I have enough money to do another one.
Okay, let's try it.
This is just like IRL gambling.
Yeah, but there's no stakes.
See?
It's telling me to try again.
There's no stakes because it's a video game.
I blew all my savings!
I blew them all!
Honey!
Wait, I can sell here.
The lobster.
I keep the spines.
Okay, we got more money now.
Okay.
We're gonna win it big right now.
Speedpanda, you're welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Twitter.
I could've won $100.
Dollars.
Come on!
I have no more money!
Okay, let's fish for more money.
See?
I'm a lesson you guys.
Don't...
Don't be like me, okay?
I'm your...
Lesson.
Just...
Don't be like me.
Is this a really...
Not rare one because...
Because the thing was so far back?
A creature.
It's a grouper.
It's huge.
Guys, when I get to rank 2...
We'll do another one.
Rodrigo, thanks for the 5 gifted!
Okay.
I will...
I will open up the lobby soon.
Sorry.
I'm having fun with gambling now.
Now I just wanna keep gambling.
Let's go gambling!
You can hold again after mashing.
Oh, you can?
Ayee.
No lobby, only gamble.
You only have to mash till it passes the bar.
Oh.
Just mash through the white barrier.
Grampy, thanks for the gifted!
Minto is about to seal our gacha luck.
I don't know.
You know that I have like...
Or rather, if you watched me before, you know that I have...
quite possibly some of...
the worst luck...
in existence.
I might have some of the worst luck...
to ever...
be gifted to a person.
I have...
zero negative stats in luck.
I have negative stats in luck stat.
Then why did you gamble?
Cuz it's fun!
Cuz it's so much fun.
What do you mean, except in Holocure?
I did though, I got a shiny...
Okay, I have a question about Holocure.
For anybody who knows.
For the fish...
There's an achievement to fish all fish.
Right?
Does that include the shiny fish?
Or...
Do I just have to get all types of fish?
It doesn't need the shiny ones.
Where's my fish here?
Hello?
Fish?
Hello, fish?
Do I have bait?
Oh...
I might not have bait.
I think I have enough bait now.
How many did I get just now?
Why doesn't it tell me?
Where's my bait?
You can only have max five?
Oh, hello, game.
Press B.
Oh my god!
Why did it let me do so much?
Ha!
Three, two, one.
Mash, mash, mash.
You guys are so right.
Thank you.
I thought I had to press the whole time.
I got a small oyster.
Oyster?
I hardly know her.
Literal clickbait.
We're casting long and hard and wide and far.
We're casting far.
The spectral pole?
What's that?
What's the spectral pole?
I got a clownfish.
I ranked up!
I'm a scout again.
Need more.
Scout.
I'm a scout.
You can change your tag.
From scout to scout three.
Three.
Oh, I see.
I've been blocking the...
I'm blocking the... what's it called?
The bait, but I have three left.
I see it now.
Sorry, you guys couldn't see it.
Oh, you can kind of see it through my armpit.
Don't look at my armpit.
Minto, you are the same but different.
Yeah, I said I would be.
Oh my gosh, I've never had two before.
Oh my gosh.
Is this a rare fish?
This is the biggest fish?
This is the most...
I got a small swordfish!
Hi!
Oh my gosh.
It said it was a quest.
Hold on.
Let's go to the quest board.
How much does that sell for?
It sells for 24!
I'm one dollar off of a...
For a lottery ticket.
I...
Oh, whoopsie.
I don't quite know how I want to play this game yet.
Just because...
There's also the...
What the...
Oh, sorry.
I'm like clicking out of the game on accident.
Because I'm like dragging, you know?
I'm like dragging the camera and so I'm accidentally clicking out of my game.
There's like an aquarium too, isn't there?
I went inside some of the buildings before.
Oh, I died.
I died again.
Window jump scare?
Let's just take the bridge.
Like a normal person.
Is it...
Like, there's so many things in here, right?
There's so much you can do in here.
What do you mean I'm not a valid fish?
Is this a valid fish?
Insert.
Oh my gosh, he's in there!
Can I... Am I creating this fish?
Wait, no, no, no.
I don't want to...
Put the fish in there.
Why did I take him out?
Insert fish.
Okay.
Now this.
Insert fish.
Wait.
No, no, don't retrieve!
No, no, no.
It's only one fish per person.
Huh?
One per player?
I thought I was filling up the aquarium.
Okay, we'll put our spine in there.
Let's go look at him.
Wow, little spine.
Oh, I thought this was like fill up the aquarium with all your fish.
Oh, little spine in the aquarium.
Wow.
What's this over here?
Just a box.
Oh my gosh.
I'm in it.
I'm in the box.
I'm also partially in the void.
And then there's this thing here.
The vending machine.
What do these do?
Literally just a beer.
Oh, we can get wine.
What's a shrink soda?
And a big soda?
And a water?
And a canned boost?
Wow.
What does the beer do?
Beer o'clock.
Don't go swimming with the beer guys.
Oh yeah.
Claim reward.
Oh my gosh.
We made a lot of money.
Scroll down for more.
What is this?
Alien cosmetic.
Special title cosmetic.
Five thousand dollars.
How many scratch tickets can we get with that?
Fill all journal entries in radiant quality.
What the hell does that even mean?
Oh, I have a new appearance.
I'm the strongest warrior.
Check the shop.
Is this the shop in here?
Hello?
Wow, he wears his fish.
I thought it was a beard.
Did he just purr at me?
Oh, cricket's bait.
Leech's bait.
Wow, these are expensive.
It's four hundred dollars per bait.
That's insane.
Rod luck.
Oh, I need that.
Camp tier.
Wait, so if I get two guys to come in here, can we get our camp tier to go even more high?
Oh, they're licenses.
The bait is cheap.
Oh, it's individual.
Oh my gosh.
Animate eyes.
Oh wait, these have...
They feel like some of these...
Some of these...
This one matches my freak retreat.
Unfortunately, the tooth for my cat is on the wrong side.
Bite slip.
Oh, we can get little hats and shirts and everything.
It's an MLM shirt?
But it's... Shouldn't it be MLF?
Right.
What?
I was thinking MLM like a... What's it called?
Like a pyramid scheme.
Is it not a pyramid scheme T-shirt?
I'm not sure anymore.
What's the other...
Men...
MLM, I thought he was gonna come to my house and sell me candles or cosmetics or something.
That's what I thought.
What?
Oh, we can get glasses.
Oh, we can get chalk.
Wait, can we draw and stuff?
Oh my gosh, stop.
We can get instruments.
We can really make this into Outer Wilds.
But right now, all I wanna do is buy gambles.
I wanna buy gambles.
Okay, I'm gonna go to... Wait, where's the gamble?
I'm gonna die!
I'm gonna go back to the gambling area.
And we're gonna...
And then I'll open it up.
You guys better just chill and let me gamble, okay?
I'm gonna die.
This way!
Okay.
Alright, just let me gamble.
Let me... Let me...
Let me give away my life savings, okay everybody?
No punching?
Yeah, no punching.
Oh, I thought that was a secret.
I'm kind of interested in more secrets too.
Woah!
Woah, woah.
This looks like an out of bounds.
Wait, this is kind of creepy.
Oh, it is out of bounds.
Wait, I can't go through here.
Why have it open then, huh?
Why is it even open if I can't go through?
Where's your bones?
Where's all your bones?
Why are these areas so mysterious, huh?
Wait, this area has to be... No!
Come on, let me in!
The illusion of freedom.
This one won't even let me pass through.
Well, shoot.
Okay.
Back to...
I'm just looking for ghost bones.
Woah!
Let's take the shortcut.
Nice.
Easy peasy.
Alrighty.
I thought I heard ghost buns.
Give me a second.
Okay.
I don't really have... I guess, don't...
You know, don't overstay your welcome.
I won't be using the chat in the game.
Be nice.
And, you know, so...
Stay, you know, you can stay for like 10 minutes or something.
And then leave, you know, 5-10 minutes.
Just so that people can have a chance to join as well and stuff.
So yeah.
Code will be shared under memberships.
This is a web fishing room color.
And I'm posting it 3, 2, 1, now!
And now I'm going to go fish for more stuff.
Oh, here we go.
Supercharge!
All I want to do is gamble.
Welcome to membership.
Thank you!
Yeah, hopefully the server doesn't crash.
I guess we'll see.
We are just fishing.
It says the room doesn't exist.
What did I just...Oh gosh!
I think the room exists.
Wait, I hear something.
I hear something.
Something is in my...
Hold, hold, hold!
Oh my god.
I can't see.
I don't even know what I caught.
I caught a large krill.
I'm going to krill myself.
I can't even see what it is.
Get out of my way!
Get out!
Fish.
Look at everybody fishing.
Oh my gosh.
Are you crying?
What is this one?
Oh my gosh!
Eleven!
Oh my god.
Wait, you guys, I think I got something kind of rare!
You guys, I think I got something kind of rare!
What did I get?
I got a dogfish.
What the hell?
What's going on?
What is that?
Oh my god.
How are you guys getting such big things?
How did you set up a picnic?
What is going on?
No way, I thought a mountain had spawned in front of us.
Oh my gosh, the title caught the super duper rare.
Rare golden bass.
Oh my gosh.
They have better gear than me?
I just started.
I'm still a scout, you guys.
I'm still...
I'm a scout.
Oh wait.
I think I don't have any more bait.
I don't have any bait.
Lesson?
Hot dog.
Gotcha.
Nope, you fail.
Oh, I can only get five, that's right.
I got a krill!
He's actually kind of expensive.
Thanks.
You're welcome.
Oyster.
I want to save my big guys, you know.
Alright, hold on.
Alright, guys.
I'll be able to afford the good stuff too once I make a lot of money from my scratch-offs, okay?
Alright, scratch-off time.
Scratch-off time.
Me and Robot are scratching off.
Here we go.
Try is $500.
It's telling me to try again.
I could win.
Is that okay?
Why is it called fishillionaire when you can only win up to $10,000?
Isn't that kind of messed up?
It's my angry cries.
What the hell?
I'm just trying to live my life and someone is punching me in the face.
What a krill.
Okay, this is the one.
Oh my gosh!
Stop you guys!
We won $100!
You need a new vacuum?
What do you mean do I need a new vacuum?
We got $100!
$100!
These eyes are freaking me out.
What is this smile?
Wait!
How much did you win?
They just ran away.
How much did they win?
Oh, Ripperoni.
Alright, this is the big box.
This is the big box.
This is the big box!
Who
just went to the bathroom on my stream?
What's going on?
I'm leaving this area.
Wait a second.
Oh my gosh, your hat matches mine.
How is that possible?
Eddie has half the same hat as me.
$500!
If only...
Okay.
Alright.
Back to...
This is... Stop flushing the toilet in my right ear!
I hate this.
This is such a mistake.
Get out of my frame!
You're blocking my shot.
I can't see anything.
Oh my god.
Where is my fish?
You guys are taking all my fish.
You can zoom out.
I got a fish.
I'm holding.
I got a large.
I was about to say a little.
He is a little herring.
Oh my gosh, you guys.
I'm almost at rank 3.
Good eye.
Welcome to my bush of barbecue.
Oh my gosh.
Splash, splash, splash.
You guys, I got something rare.
I got something rare.
I got something good.
Who the hell is farting over there?
Another dogfish.
Get out of my face.
I ranked up.
What the... Did I spawn that?
Oh, I can fish in it too.
What is this?
Why is there a tiny frog fishing right here?
What is this chaos?
What is happening?
I'm fishing in the well.
I'm now back.
Oh my gosh.
I caught something.
It better be something cool.
It better be something good.
I caught... a huge snail.
Look
at this guy just walking around with his stingray out.
Who is barking over there?
What the...
Oh my god!
That's what was farting.
It's a whoopee cushion.
Wait, hold on.
Hold on.
Oh, I missed.
Wait.
You can buy the hat you are wearing right now in game too.
It's the fear hat in the hub shop.
Why?
I'm gonna go buy it.
Wait, so is the... I guess there is not really a point to...
Saving fish, huh?
The point of this game is to really sell the fish.
I thought that you would save them too for the...
For the...
What's the word?
Hello.
You can save cool ones, but sell most.
Wait, it's this lady.
Fear hat.
I can't believe it.
That this actually is not just the women want me, fish fear me hat.
It's the exact same hat that I'm wearing.
I can't believe that it's actually the same thing.
That's so funny.
Oh my gosh.
The game got way too immersive.
That's so funny.
I'm gonna do in the pond a little bit.
Why are you staring at me like that with your sparkly eyes?
Why are you looking at me like this?
I got murdered!
Oh my God, I literally...
Hold on, I'm trying to fish.
I just got murdered by a sparkly dog.
Don't touch me, don't touch me.
Wait, how did you manage to get on that rock like that?
I got a crayfish.
What the hell is going on here?
What is this graffiti on my ground?
In my camp...
How is this graffiti?
Can I fish in this thing?
Wait, interact.
This buddy isn't yours.
I can't fish in him.
Can I fish in the buddy?
Yeah, we got vandalism going on.
Whoops, I didn't mean to do that.
Wait, get me out.
What is that?
What the hell is going on?
What is this?
Oh my God, they're giant fish!
I died.
Oh my gosh.
How do I make this?
Oh gosh, I can't even see anymore.
What's happening?
I have to jump up to see it.
Oh no, I'm gonna die.
Why are there so many fish that are so big?
What the hell is this one?
This is just a green screen fish.
Oh, it's not a fish at all.
It's a green screen.
Green screen fish.
Hey, let me in the picture.
I like woe-hoed snake right here.
The dogs are too loud!
Shut up!
The dogs are annoying.
Shut up, dogs.
I hear a lone bark in the distance.
Oh wait, I need more bait.
Why did people just set up the little buddies?
What are those things?
What are those little buddies?
Wait, this dogfish is worth more than this dogfish.
Is it the size?
How do I punch people?
How do you punch?
Size matters.
Need boxing gloves.
You have to buy the punch item.
That's so funny.
That's so funny sounding.
Excuse me.
Ruff.
Stop, your fish is right near little... Is that a frog?
What is that anyway?
I don't even know what that is.
Oh, they are dying.
They are dying in the water.
I kind of want to use that chair.
Yeah, everybody is scaring the fish away.
Get out of the water!
You are scaring the fish away.
Oh my gosh, the rubber ducky is so cute.
My oshi frog bird.
Nah, frog birds got way more style and class.
I think.
I think actually.
They are scaring the fish.
I'm gonna go over here.
What?
Stay over there.
Stop it!
It's scaring the fish!
How did you live?
Did you just come up and...
It was a run away.
I can't with this.
I can't with this lobby.
It was a drive-by kiss.
I can't believe that happened to me.
Yeah, I'm calling the cops.
I'm reporting you to the police at this very moment.
I regret nothing.
Oh my gosh.
How are you so fast over there?
Did you drink the soda?
The speedy soda?
I got another large hairy.
Okay, I need to start saving up money.
So that we can get stuff for better things.
What is going on?
That guy is eating dirt?
Just wisp things?
I got a krill.
I keep getting the same things now.
Better things equals more lottery tickets.
Oh gosh, that scared me.
Get your whale out of my face.
Guys, this is a big one!
Guys, this is a big one.
This might be my own whale!
My own movie dick!
Oh my god, please.
I got an octopus!
Octopus!
I thought wisps had claws.
Stop!
I'll kill you.
Wait, how do I show off my fish?
Everybody look at my octopus.
It's the best thing I've caught all day.
Look at it.
Yeah, look at it.
Don't punch.
Look at my octopus.
I don't care about your damn fish.
Yes, thank you.
Thank you.
Look at my octopus.
Next song?
Wait, what?
What do you mean next song?
Oh, it's a beatbox.
Wait, hold on.
I want to listen.
Hey, stop, stop, stop.
Where is the music?
Next song.
This song is terrible.
Oh, I didn't save the settings?
I didn't save the settings.
There we go.
I thought it was just...
Wait,
there are two songs going at once.
Please.
I heart peeing.
I hope that's not what you're doing.
Oh, here we go.
Okay.
Can I meow to this song?
That was great.
That was good fun.
How do I put away my octopus?
Octopus.
How do I put him away?
How do I put this guy away?
I have a letter?
I'm not checking letters on stream.
Because I'm nervous about stuff.
Switch to anything else?
Okay, I'll switch to my spine.
Oh, I'm sorry.
This is my spectral rib.
Everybody look at my rib.
Everybody.
Everybody look at...this is a piece of me.
Wait, what is your fishing rod?
Wait, what is this?
What does that mean?
Is this a ghost rod?
Find the rest of the bones.
Guys, we must find the bones.
Wait, hold on.
I want to go take...
Okay.
We must find the rest of the bones.
Right now.
Who wants to take a picture of me?
Hey, get out of my face.
Get out of my shot.
Picture, picture, picture.
We must find the rest of the bones.
Oh, I died.
Hold on.
This way.
This seems like a bone area.
This area looks a little bony.
Boned.
Boned area.
Maybe.
Octopi are extremely intelligent and one day will rule the land.
A bone zone, if you will.
Yes.
So we got the one.
We got this one and we got the other one.
Can I get a hint?
Does anybody else know?
Can I get a hint of one?
How many are there?
I don't even know.
They are high up.
Ocean.
Total of five.
Okay.
Oh, excuse me.
High up, like in the trees.
Thank you for existing.
Thank you.
Thanks for one month of membership.
Somebody needs a bounce pad.
Like the bounce shrooms?
What is this drawing?
What the?
Oh my gosh.
God.
It's so cute.
Who did this?
Smelly, smelly, smelly.
I'm doing taco.
Thank you for the 10 gifted.
Let's see.
Ocean.
And then somewhere high up.
Maybe like this one.
I got that one over there.
I know that.
Let's see if we can get a vantage point.
I see this guy everywhere.
I think if you've been here from the beginning, it might be time to...
Switch out so other people can join.
So thank you for coming in.
We're just going on honor system here, so please be honorable.
Let's see.
Maybe over here, but I just missed it.
Oh shoot.
Art style reminds me of a short hike.
I can see that.
Letter received.
Thank you!
If you're sending letters, I will check them.
I will check them off stream.
I got...
I got a spectral skull!
Yippee!
Ok, that's three.
Thanks for the letters.
How do I get...You guys both have ghost rods.
I'm jealous.
I want one.
I have a normal rod.
Two more.
This will be my lucky time.
Right now.
Luck, luck, luck, luck.
I mean, I might as well just...Wow, it's zero and zero.
Oh wait, I just noticed.
Three, seven.
I just noticed that.
Oh, nineteen, twelve.
Oh my god, stop.
I thought it had to match the number and then also the letters down here.
I was like, wow, this is tough.
It's not about the type of rod you have, but how you use that matters.
Yeah, I know, but...
I want a ghost rod.
I hate this game.
Okay, so we found that one.
This game is rigged.
Let this be a warning for you all.
I'm gonna die.
I lived.
I lived!
So we have...
Oh, I think I need to go get the spine back from the...
From the aquarium probably, huh?
What is this side- Why are you side-eyeing me for, huh?
Why is this so rude?
Rude.
Side-eyeing me for, huh?
How is it going?
It's going fine.
If Min uses the ghost rod, she gets STFB.
Same type fishing bonus.
Oh my god.
Wait, can I take my fish back?
Okay.
I got my fish from the...
This is so stupid.
They don't even move.
They just sit there.
Oh, this is... The tank is not even big enough for them.
This is so sad.
I don't even know what that is.
This is so cute.
Hello, hello.
Oh, I made it.
Look at you fishing over there.
How wholesome.
Oh, I did something.
I caught an octopus, so I get 25 dollars.
Catch a lake fish.
Catch a 9 out of 10 ocean fish.
I don't even know if the spectral one is any good.
You know, the spectral rod.
It's cosmetic.
I guess that's okay.
You know, whatever.
But I have to use it.
Yeah, it's the ghost rod.
I have to use it.
It's literally made for me.
Can I get another hint?
Maybe this one is the hint.
There is one nearby the lighthouse.
I got that one.
Or is there another one by the lighthouse?
There is another.
And I'm also close to one.
Oh gosh, wait, I clicked out of the game.
Hello, I'm looking for bones.
Do you know where the bones are?
Wait!
How did you get that bone?
Where is it?
Wait, how did you get out there?
He disappeared.
Wait, he disappeared!
Oh hello!
Okay, I'm watching.
I'm watching.
Wait, are you leading me still?
I'm following.
I hope this isn't a trap.
Thank you!
We got the femur!
Thank you, thank you!
Alright, now we go to the lighthouse and then go find that one.
One more!
That one was hidden so well.
That one was like really...
I don't think I would have been able to find it very easily.
Of all the places to land, just immediate death.
Okay, by the lighthouse.
By the lighthouse.
I can't tell if he wants me to follow him.
I want to find this one myself.
No help.
No help this time.
What we have learned here is that our Oshi will just follow random strangers.
By the lighthouse.
Did you guys watch the...
The... Okay, so I got that one over there.
Did you guys watch the over the garden wall...
Short that was made?
Not yet?
It's really short.
But it's so cute.
It's really sweet.
I'm looking into the trees from above.
I'm not seeing anything.
I was hoping you'd bring it up.
Yeah, it was so cute.
It's just a...
It's like a stop animation short thing.
If I were bones, where would I be hidden?
The bone zone.
Saying the last one is near the lighthouse might be misleading.
Is it just in this general vicinity then?
I have four of them.
So this is the last one.
I did the parkour.
What did I just hear?
Sounded like a music.
What's that sound?
Oh, it's a guitar.
A guitar.
An interpretive dance.
Play Wonderwall.
He's like, I don't know how to play that one.
How are you so small?
Small cat.
Hey!
I'm gonna go buy things too.
How do I buy a boxing glove?
Oh, I need to unlock my camp tier.
Maybe.
Oh wait.
Oh wait!
No, I don't!
I can... Oh gosh.
Cannot afford.
Jeez.
Oh boy.
Oh wait, I can buy titles.
Silly guy.
Just a silly little guy.
Little lad.
I'm a little guy.
Oh, sloppy doggy style.
Stinker dinker.
I'm just gonna buy the gay title.
I kinda want the good boy.
Kitten title.
Goober title.
Yapper title.
Chalks are fun.
The discord kitten title.
How do I get an eyepatch?
I want an eyepatch too.
Do I have to actually rank up my title?
Or rank up my...thing?
I have to level up?
I bought the boxing glove.
But don't tell him.
How did you get in here?
I thought this was a private location.
Am I doing it right?
I can't beat anybody.
I can't beat him up.
Oh my god.
Fight club.
How do I push you into the air?
Wait, line up, line up, line up, line up.
Get in a line, get in a line, get in a line.
No cutting!
Alright, go to the end of the line.
Go to the end of the line.
Okay, whatever, that works too.
Alright, when I punch you, go to the end of the line.
How do you make me go so far though?
Don't look at me with that creepy-ass smile.
What the hell is this?
Stop it!
Thanks for that boss.
Group punch everybody!
Group punch!
Oh my god, the whoopee cushion scared me.
I'm going to fish in this toilet.
Hey, this is my toilet.
Get out, get out, get out.
New meet and greet meta?
Probably.
Nice punchline boss.
Thank you, Zeno.
Hey, you took my fish!
How did you get that?
This is the one, three, two, kiss me slap line.
Wait, why don't I get any fish?
Where is my fish?
Hello?
How are you guys...Oh, I got one finally.
Fishing in the skippity toilet.
I wish you didn't say that.
I got a goldfish.
That's kind of messed up.
Getting a goldfish from...Oh my gosh, I'm so close to ranking up.
Getting a goldfish from a toilet is so sad, is it not?
I wish you didn't read that.
Staff morale increase.
Thanks for that sir.
Thanks for that boss.
I got a salmon.
Yay!
I reached rank five!
I probably saved it.
I remember I once got a betta fish from the fair.
And I loved him so much, I fed him non-stop.
I was like, here's some more food.
And he'd be like...
And I'd be like, ah, he likes food.
Here's some more food.
And he'd go...
And I'd be like, ah, here's some more food.
And...
I actually thought I was gonna kill him.
But he survived for a couple of years.
A bow fin.
Alright, let's go find that other bone.
Rain's coming in.
Wait, what's that do?
Does it make betta fish?
Does betta fish come out in the rain?
Yes?
Okay, okay.
Nevermind, we're fishing boys, we're fishing.
Do you want help with the bone?
Maybe a hint.
A tiny hint.
I got the same thing.
Come on, we want the good fish.
Follow the sound of the incessant barking.
No, I don't want someone to lead me.
It's on the island.
Corner.
Hint is corner.
Where's the good fish?
Oh, I caught a branch?
That's not even a fish.
I didn't even get a fish, I got a stick.
I didn't even get a... What?
I thought the good fish was supposed to come out.
Instead I get... Oh, oh my god.
Hi baby.
Stop meowing, I thought you were my cat, but my cat is actually meowing at me.
What's up baby girl?
Hey girl, stop meowing.
I'm trying to hear my cat, my own cat meowing.
Come here baby girl.
Come here girl.
It's paused.
I keep... She wants out, but...
What do you want girl?
I know you want out.
Hold on.
Let me catch a fish first.
Stop catching my fish!
What's up with this?
You keep putting it in the same spot as me and you're catching all my fish.
Stop being so rude.
I'll kick you from this lobby.
Oh, I don't have bait.
I don't have bait.
Wait, where can I get some?
Oh wait, it's still raining, kind of.
I need a bait.
Come here little girl.
Nevermind, hold on girly.
Oh, my bad.
It's time to fish.
I got a...
Another goldfish.
Is it because I'm by the toilet?
Oh my god.
Oh,
I got a rainbow trout.
Okay, hold on.
Let me...
Girl, come here baby.
You are so small.
You are so cute.
My cute little girl.
Maybe she'll meow for you guys.
Hold on.
Let me turn off... Oh, no, no, no.
Let me turn off the music.
And let me turn off my noise gate.
Come here Pais.
You guys hear her?
It's probably hard to hear.
Oh, the BGM.
Sorry.
Do you hear her?
Yeah?
You are so sweet baby girl.
You are so sweet.
Yeah, you...
I don't want to put my finger in your ear.
Come here.
Do you hear her?
Oh, she's flopping on the ground.
Stop it.
Those are the postcards.
Those are the Patreon postcards.
Come here.
Yeah, she's a squeaker.
She's super squeaky.
Come here.
She's rolling all over the place.
Over
here.
Just one last squeak.
One last squeak.
Come over here.
I'm sorry guys.
I'm trying to get her to squeak.
One last squeak.
Stop licking yourself.
Come here.
You are so sweet.
I love
you.
Okay, I let her out.
Sorry, I couldn't get the last one squeak out of her.
What was it at?
Like 75?
Whatever.
Okay.
Okey dokey.
Alright, let's find a bone.
Corner was the hint.
Corner.
Corner of the world?
Corner of the beach?
Let's see.
Thank you for the blessed pies noises.
Of course.
Under here?
Oh gosh, I'm stuck now.
Around here, no?
Corner, corner, corner.
I just got here with a nice hat.
Thanks my girl.
Did you see the new Over the Garden Wall stop motion short?
I did!
My only thing is I wish it were longer.
But it made me tear up.
Oh my gosh, the other day I watched the concert.
They did a concert on Twitch.
And it was so...
Beautiful.
It was funny because it was also very like...
Wait, wrong way?
What do you mean wrong way?
It was just so...
Can you reach that?
Even Elijah Wood showed up.
Oh shoot.
It was like at some tiny little...
I say tiny little.
I actually don't know.
On the Twitch stream it looked so much more different than...
How it did in like...
I've watched some...
Some videos of it.
That people took and they...
It looked really nice, but on the live stream itself...
It looked kind of like...
It was like very orange and strange looking.
But it was like at some art gallery.
Corner, corner, corner.
If you guys are mentioning this one by the way...
I've already gotten it.
That one over there.
I've already gotten it, so...
Elijah Wood shows up everywhere.
That guy is so cool.
He's like so chill.
I don't even think he...
Thinks he's like a celebrity, you know.
Corner, corner.
Like this corner.
I'm outside the bounds.
I got all five!
Do you wear wigs?
Whoops, I died.
I feel like the...
Cast of Lord of the Rings are just so...
I don't know.
I don't know really much anything about them, but they...
Have this like appearance of just being...
Such chill, fun people.
That interview was so funny.
You know what's so funny too is I...
When I first saw it, I didn't realize...
That it was...
Oh my god, your face.
I pooted on stream.
I didn't realize that...
That it was one of the actors.
I didn't realize it was...
Sam?
What's that guy's name?
What's the other one with Frodo?
Was it Sam?
Oh, it was Mary.
I didn't realize it was one of the guys.
I thought it was just some random...
Weirdo interviewer.
Oh, I can increase my rod power.
Okay.
Wait, how do I get the spectral one?
I got all of them now.
How much wood could an Elijah Wood...
Would if Elijah Wood could Elijah Wood?
Waterfall.
I know waterfall.
Over here.
Why you got...
Why you got that look on your face for?
Sussy.
I waterfalled too hard?
I think.
Don't forget if you've been in...
The lobby for a little bit.
I don't know if it's full or not.
Honestly, I haven't been running into so many people.
But if you've been in the lobby for a little bit...
Please allow others to have a chance to enter the lobby.
The...
Code is in members.
So...
Yeah.
Just allow other people to...
To come in.
Where is members?
Like the community tab?
Like I posted it as a members community post?
Different waterfall?
Where was another one?
Where was another waterfall?
This game is so relaxing.
Say maybe 10 minutes off limit?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's what I said earlier.
But good to remind.
Hello.
Did you just hiss at... What the hell is that guy?
What is that?
How?
There is stealth fishing.
Can I get up there?
Hi.
No ghost allowed in the fort.
No.
I can make it.
Hi.
Oh my god.
Wait!
That's so close.
Ok, hold on.
We are on a mission.
We gotta go find another waterfall.
Waterfall, waterfall.
Is this where they died?
Oh my god!
Why is there a toilet in here?
Spectral hand!
I lost...
The game.
I only have 29 dollars.
Ok, I'll come back.
500 dollars.
Don't mind me.
I'm just fishing behind you.
What are you doing here anyway?
You're not even fishing.
Noice.
Goodbye.
A tiny koi.
I
can barely see it.
I know, right?
Just chilling.
We're just chilling.
Just vibing.
Just fishing.
You know?
I think it's time to gamble.
No!
We have to get 500 dollars.
And then we can gamble everything.
Then we won't even have a life to gamble away because we...
We'll have...
We will have a ghost rod.
Why don't the fish like me?
Why don't the fish like me, huh?
Why don't they ever come to me?
Oh my god, everybody is hissing at me.
Oh, I got one!
Have you looked at your own hat?
Do you think it actually is a debuff?
Oh, we got a small carp.
I guess... Oh my gosh, can you imagine?
The fish fear is a real debuff hat.
They said we fear nothing.
Okay, I challenged them and now they're...
Now they're fine.
Oh, a huge goldfish.
Okay, we got to get more bait.
Yeah, this game does have a bait system.
So...
What did I...
I caught a koi.
We get money for that.
Nice.
If I just buy a bunch of stuff...
Or rather, if I catch a bunch of stuff...
I caved and bought the game.
Oh, and it's raining here too.
Nice.
Thanks for catching the octopus earlier.
They're my absolute favorite animal.
Really?
Okay, nice.
We got a...
Crab!
That's...
The tiniest crab I might have ever seen in my entire afterlife.
Crab.
Octopuses are pretty cute.
Don't be so crabby.
Look at everybody just chilling.
Oh, I got another thing.
Nice.
Skull.
Wow, what is that?
How are you guys both catching them?
Come on, give me a fish.
Come on, stupid fish.
Oh, just insult the fish and... Oh my goodness.
Okay, insult the fish and they come to you.
Hi, Saifa.
It's nice to see you enjoying yourself.
Having so much fun with this.
I got work in five hours, so it's time to sleep.
Good night, Minto and Wisp.
Good night!
Oh my gosh, why didn't you go to sleep sooner?
A large bullfin.
Cause I got work.
Someone said it's funny when you kick someone.
Do you want to try?
Maybe.
Question.
Do you read missed superchats between streams?
I wonder if you saw my whole Snake Eater song.
When did you send that?
Yes.
Sometimes I go back and read the ones that I missed on stream.
But I didn't... When did you?
During the final boss fight.
Oh, I thought you meant like recently.
I thought you meant like...
Wait, you mean like during Snake Eater?
Has anyone joked about the master bait yet?
Yeah, I'm a master baiter.
You know, I have all the... Well, I actually don't have the best bait.
I only have little worms, you know.
So...
But I remember people... I think I remember you sending it though.
During... it?
Sometimes I might read and I don't react if I don't... Especially if it's during a final fight like that.
Sorry.
I'm gonna go sell.
Salmon.
Yummy.
Nice, okay.
Happy belated Dia de los Muertos.
I just love Latinas, Minto.
Thank you... Oh gosh, you scared me.
Hello!
You made it in!
Oops.
Oh, let's sell.
Let's see... I don't want to sell all my cool guys.
I think we might have to sell everything to get enough money.
This stick is five dollars.
Goldfish.
Goldfin.
My dogfish.
My octopus.
Oh, we're so close actually.
Oh my gosh.
I think I've seen you around for quite a bit.
So if you don't mind leaving so other people can come in.
Thank you.
I too wish for Minto...
Stop!
I'm from the Fish and Wildlife Commission.
You don't need a license to fish, do you?
You do?
That's a certain age up here in Canada.
I thought fishing was a free... What the hell is that?
That's the ugliest fish I've ever seen.
Hey, I'm fishing here.
Depends on the place.
Can't just kill... I'm not killing them, I'm catching them and I'm releasing them.
I'm currently doing an MGS3 foxhound run.
Holy moly.
Good luck!
If you are catching a lot of tree branches, don't take it.
You have to stick it to the...
You take the fish and then you throw them back in.
Unfortunately, a percentage die when you release them.
Is it because they have the thing stuck in their mouth?
Catch and release is still detrimental.
What?
This is why I've never fished... Well, I've fished before, but it was with my uncle.
What the hell was that?
Oh my gosh.
Wait, it's the little swirly guy.
It's the guy with the swirly bottom mouth.
Makes me happy to know you read your old messages.
Sent my first ever Akasupa during your 3.0 with a super sappy message.
Wait, I'm gonna have to go back and say it again though.
There were so many for that stream.
But yeah, I do try because, you know, I can't catch all of them always, but...
I do try to go back and look through stuff.
And I read people's comments and stuff on stream.
Finally, I got a fish.
I might have to do the upgrade where you like...
Get the... What's it called?
Where you get the higher rank percentage of fish, you know.
The catch rate upgrade?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think I need...
What the?
Did you just catch that?
Oh my god.
Better bait helps.
I know, I'm not getting anything.
This sucks.
This game is making me sleepy though.
This game is making me so sleepy.
I did level my rod once.
Maybe I should save on the spectral.
Until we have a better everything overall.
A large mouth bass.
Frog guy for upgrades.
Yeah, yeah.
Hope you're having a wonderful time on the game.
This comfy background noise is making my time sick enjoyable.
No!
Grosses!
Feel better!
Oh my gosh, I didn't recognize you at first.
Your profile picture.
Rod power is important.
Yeah.
Okay, after this fish... After next fish, I'll level up.
I have to
get going kind of soon-ish.
Hello?
Fish.
Whoa, what is that one?
It's like a little bomb.
Looks like a little mine in the water.
The gang is all...
You look too happy.
What's taking you so long?
Get that fish!
Oh my gosh.
You got it!
Everybody has the spectral rod.
I'm so jealous.
New profile pic of my dragoon in a dragoon suit during the day 21.
They still think I'm a birch.
Wait!
Oh, nope, that's not me.
It's everybody else around me, but me.
Today is Godzilla's birthday.
Oh, wait!
They announced a new movie coming out.
So much Godzilla content recently.
Okay, I can't stand this anymore.
I'm not getting anything, you guys.
This sucks.
I'm leaving.
Oh, there's another one.
Cute!
Booty!
Oh, cute!
The cool ass.
Pokemon that resembles me.
Gengar.
So I can get a leech's license.
I'll probably bring all the fish to the yard.
I think we need the rod chance up too.
Since you like Hideo Kojima games...
Yeah, I plan on playing Zone of the Enders someday.
Gain a small amount of cash for every catch?
That's huge!
Catches have a higher chance of being smaller fish.
That's strange.
I guess for specific quests you would need it.
Pop-ups appear during the fishing minigame.
Clicking them gives cash, but missing them hurts you.
Get the crickets?
OK.
I'm going to get the lucky hook.
And I'm going to get the crickets.
And I'm going to get...
Chance up and...
Max bathe up.
OK.
How does it hurt you?
Is there health in this game?
These cost money!
I at least have 10 of them.
I have 10 crickets.
OK, I'm going to get all the big boys now, guys.
And yeah, I am using the crickets.
Equip your hook too.
Oh, thank you.
I got a leech!
Leech!
You came back to me!
Oh my gosh, we linked up!
Wait, how do I... Oh, there we go.
Lucky hook.
Mint, what?
What did I say?
What did I do?
Oh, I had to... My hook?
Yeah, someone said remember to attach your hook too.
So I said yes, OK.
And I didn't... I hadn't attached it.
I hate this world!
I thought they were giving me legitimate advice!
A large perch.
I'm fishing here, guys.
My brain...
My brain... I'm fish brained right now.
I'm not thinking about no internet lingo or whatever you youngsters are talking about on the interwebs.
I'm talking about real slimy fish.
It's fishing hours.
Oh, I got a huge walleye.
It's a fishing time.
How much money am I collecting from this, I wonder?
I'm fish brained.
Are fish slimy?
Fish are...
Fish
are...
Slippery?
They can be slimy?
Usually, generally?
OK.
When am I gonna catch a...
Fishing for me!
I love fish.
Fishing is a patience game, guys.
You gotta just sit there and hope that you one day catch a fish.
I have something on the board.
I caught a leech!
What is my... What is my title that I can get?
Wait, is it under...
How do I change my title again?
Oh, here.
Nightcrawler.
The pretty title.
The prettiest.
Tenderfoot.
What did I get that from?
Koi boy.
Everybody is right here.
I think it's about time though that you guys switch out.
So if you have been here for a bit...
Time to switch out.
Let some other people come in and have a chance.
That guy is fishing from the toilet.
So thank you guys.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my god, those eyes.
It's so scary.
Why you gotta look at me with them eyes?
I like those ones too though.
I like these ones too.
Minto hasn't switched out this whole time.
Okay, I'm just gonna leave the room then.
Oh, oh, I accidentally...
Am I gonna catch a fish?
Everybody literally here has caught a fish but me.
Thank you guys, thank you.
Pack up and I'll see you guys later.
Oh, goodbye.
Don't, don't, don't like...
Oh, me!
It's my turn!
Oh my god.
Stop kissing me, I'm trying to...
I'm trying to fish!
What's wrong with y'all?
Y'all don't know the fishing life.
Did I just hear someone laugh?
Fishing ain't about...
Team Alien?
Big Minto laugh?
Thank you!
What the heck?
Why?
Thank you.
What is that fish?
It's ugly though.
What is that?
It looks like a dog.
Why does it look like that?
Oh, are you sad that I called your fish ugly?
It's really a good fish catch.
Oh god!
I'm going back.
No, wait!
No, why?
Why do I always die?
Is it my destiny as a ghost to just always die?
Why?
I'm gonna check out this little pond right here.
I showed you my fish.
And I mean, it took up the whole screen.
It was a grand fish.
It was great.
I'm dead.
That's why I'm just like in games.
Am I supposed to die to...
To match me?
Look at this dramatic.
This is the...
Metal Gear Solid 5 scene when you're...
When you're in the truck with Skull Face.
If you die in fish game, you die in real life.
Oh, got me one dollar.
Thank you for hosting today, Minto.
I was fine.
Thanks for joining.
That MGS5 scene when you're fishing.
Thanks for the letters, guys.
I will check them off stream.
It's not that I don't trust you or anything.
It's just that I don't want to...
Accidentally have something happen, you know?
That's all.
Welcome, welcome.
I got the game so I could join with y'all, but...
Wanted to get some cosmetics first...
And ended up being rizzed up midi guitar.
Wait, what?
Is some guy helping me get the spectral rod instead?
What the hell?
You got rizzed?
Oh my gosh.
Web fishing rizz.
Did that mail bug get fixed?
I don't know.
Right before this stream, I had a friend message me...
And she was just like, by the way...
Maybe be careful with web fishing because I had someone...
That hacked into my game without the code.
And then was like spamming stuff.
And then also was...
And then was also like...
Making her character do crazy things and everything.
But they were disguised as a dev.
And...
Um...
But I wonder too if maybe it was because...
She, like, maybe it's a...
Maybe it's someone like targeting people on Twitch.
You know?
Because everyone that I've seen talk about that has been like Twitch streamers.
They probably just go to the...
Who's playing web fishing.
Oh, I have three.
I have three crickets left.
I was like, I have no more crickets.
Um, so...
I think maybe it's...
Maybe...
Maybe I would be safer is all.
Oh, oh gosh!
It's a big one, boys!
I got a large king salmon!
I think the dev said they fixed it on Twitter.
Oh, okay.
Nice!
Big fish, big fish, big fish.
You are king.
Remember when so many VTubers used to sing king?
What's like the VTuber song now?
We don't really have one, I feel.
Nowadays, not like every VTuber...
Goes for.
Still king.
Oh, idol?
Like the U.S.O.B.
song?
Huge perch.
Let's go sell some stuff.
Oh, actually, wait, hold on.
Let's wait, I have one more cricket.
So I'll use my cricket and then I'll...
Creepy nut songs.
Plastic love.
Yeah, but karaoke and covers I think are different.
I've not been watching VTubers long enough, probably not much more than a year.
That's okay.
Kyofu all back.
Oh yeah, I wanted to cover that too though.
If I cover it, you better still watch it, okay?
Guys!
I think it's a big one!
I think it's a really big guy!
I got...
I got a shiny!
I got a star!
A shining large bow fin!
Fish fact, Pacific salmon will slowly rot to death after returning to their spawning grounds.
I know that, it's so sad.
Wow!
We got a shining!
I have to go back to get more bait.
I can't believe I got a shiny!
Nice.
Hi there.
Who's kissing?
Who's kissing out here?
Let's see.
Crickets are kind of expensive.
I have so many perches.
Wow, the leech is expensive.
King salmon is 134.
I want to sell it, but I also don't want to, you know?
Who farted?
You!
This guy here, hello!
Hello, hello!
Welcome, welcome in.
You know, we're web fishing, we're chilling.
Okay guys, I'm gonna go by.
I have to get going in about 10 minutes.
So sad.
This has been so relaxing though, just kind of chilling with you guys.
Sorry that it's a much shorter stream today.
Oh gosh, I think I'm going into the water.
But thank you guys for being all good and everything.
Picnic!
Oh, this is how you get the picnic blanket.
We can just have a whole picnic area.
Metal detector.
Hold down to search for hidden treasure around the map?
Wait.
We can find hidden treasure?
Okay.
Wait, stop, stop, stop.
How do I...
Miscellaneous?
Oh, king title.
Wow!
Royalty.
Alright, metal detector.
I don't know how to...
What the?
You stole the treasure from me!
How dare you!
Oh my god.
It was my first treasure and it got stolen from under my nose!
So rude!
How dare you!
I take it all back.
I said you guys were being good.
Not being good at all.
You're stealing my tre... Wait, is there literally nothing else?
Was that the only treasure left on the island?
No way!
The only treasure on the island got stolen from me!
Wait, I need to get some bait.
Why are these little buddy guys all over the place?
Take your pets home with you when you leave, please.
There really is nothing left.
There's bait over there.
Only on sand.
Oh, okay, okay, okay.
Okay, okay, okay.
Only on sand, everybody.
Hold on, we gotta get bait so we can try for some big fish in the rain.
Oh, it is not only on sand.
Never mind!
There's nothing left, you guys!
I'm so sad right now.
I'm so sad!
Go away!
I don't wanna see your stinky face anymore!
I got robbed.
I got robbed!
Someone's up there.
My one treasure.
What are you guys doing over there?
Creeping behind me.
You're here to steal my treasure?
You're here to steal my fish?
A little
fish.
Fishing time.
Do the different lures do anything or are they just...
Cosmetic as well?
A huge angelfish!
What are you showing off?
Is that the angelfish?
That's the one I just caught.
The biggest treasure is still right here on our screens.
I'm not worth anything!
You can't sell me for a price!
I need cold hard cash!
What are you talking about?
The hat.
I need...
Oh god!
That scared the hell out of me.
Oh my god!
I see your fish!
Thank you!
Put it away!
I'm trying to catch fish here.
One day I will have caught a ginormous fish and I will shove it in your faces.
Oh I leveled up!
Yay!
Are you showing off the treasure that you found?
From stealing it?
Stealing it with the metal detector?
You got it.
I got what?
Take my money.
Thank you.
Mint doesn't know how much ghost meat goes for on the black market.
Ectoplasm?
Wait, the ectoplasm sails back?
How many bones do we need for a spectral maid?
The hip bone's connected to the tail bone.
The tail bone's connected to the butt bone.
The butt bone's connected to the leg bone.
The leg bone's connected to the foot bone.
Okay, there's gotta be treasure over here.
There's gotta be treasure up here.
What did I get?
I got a soda tab!
I got a button!
Oh my god, there's tons of stuff up here.
There's tons of stuff up here.
Where is it?
Hello?
Beep.
Am I stupid?
Where the hell is it?
Dramdor, thank you for the 20 gifted.
Thank you so much.
Wish I was connected to your butt bone, stop.
Stop.
Offering 1 million dollars for proof of the paranormal.
Wait, actually?
No, did I lose it?
Oh, no I didn't.
I feel like I'm gonna lose it though.
Where is it, you guys?
Is it on one of the hills?
You think?
Oh!
We found it!
A soda tab.
Can I sell all this stuff?
Isn't Minto proof of the paranormal?
I mean...
Filthy, filthy, filthy.
Yeah, but like...
You wouldn't...
You wouldn't like...
You wouldn't... Wait, stop making my hat bigger.
You wouldn't sell me as proof of the paranormal, right?
You wouldn't...
You wouldn't do that.
Oh my gosh, I can't stop making the hat bigger.
You wouldn't do that, because if you did that, then you would have no more Minto streams.
You wouldn't do that so that you wouldn't sell me...
You wouldn't sell me for money!
Would you?
Would you sell me for money?
I think I'm gonna end today's stream.
Oh my god, my hat is really tiny.
Who's punching me?
Stop, I'm AFK.
Wait, what's that?
Hold on.
Wait, hold on.
I'm gonna get that.
No, no, no.
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
I want that spot.
Hold on, I want that spot.
No one else take it.
It's mine.
Oh, it's gone.
No!
Hi, James Randy Foundation.
She's right here.
Two bucks for Minto.
Take it or leave it.
Are those spots with the little thing... Are those better?
You belong to the Kaiser Corporation now.
No!
It's such a chill stream, I hope.
You could stream this again when you just want to relax.
Yeah, this has been really nice.
Thank you.
Can be company during my long drive today.
Drive safe.
Best I can do is tree footing.
Wait, I'm trapped down here.
Stop showing off your stupid face.
It's so big.
Into the water.
Okay, I'm safe up here.
This is fun, guys.
Thank you.
Hopefully we can fish again some other day.
My schedule for this week will be up.
But probably not until later tonight.
This was a lot of fun.
Thank you guys for fishing with me.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you for being so good.
I will see you guys later.
Enjoy the rest of your weekend.
Thank you.
Bye bye.
Have a good night.